And the correct answer is the first one--any Las Vegas algorithm can be turned into
a Monte Carlo algorithm and the reason for that is the following--
In a Las Vegas algorithm, we said that the running time was polynomial with a certain probability
and that means that we can let the algorithm run a few times, so sometimes it will take
polynomial running time, sometime it would take exponential running time like this.
So this is suppose to be the running time and let's say in the first time it's also exponential
and we basically jut watch over the algorithm and as soon as it takes longer than polynomial time
we stop it, we cut it off, and that would then give us exactly a Monte Carlo algorithm
because here we said for this approach we demand that when we get the solution
that solution is suppose to be the best possible one.
So here the algorithm would also produce the best possible solution but we stopped it.
We are stuck with some suboptimal solution or even no solution.
Here the same thing as well, but then we started the next time and it just uses polynomial time
and then we use that solution and this is exactly
how a Monte Carlo algorithm would behave as well.
It produces the best solution with a certain probability and in this case here
this probability is dependent on the running time of the Las Vegas algorithm,
which sometimes will be polynomial and sometimes will be exponential.